bonjour leurs accusé merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france vous avez
donc été soigné à l'hôpital de la timone
comment est ce que vous vous sentez
comment allez vous et comment s'est
passé votre traitement exactement bah
écoute et aujourd'hui je me sens très
bien j'ai quasiment plus de symptômes
mais à part l'odorat et le goût qui ne
sont toujours pas revenus
mais j'ai plus tous les maux de tête la
fatigue la nausée que je pouvais avoir
précédemment
après pour ce qui s'agit du traitement à
écouter à partir du moment où je me suis
fait dépister moi je me suis fait
dépister le 21
j'étais positif dès le lendemain on m'a
appelé enfin la timone m'a appelé et m'a
proposé de prendre le traitement
donc j'y suis retourné le 23 à la je me
suis bien fait expliquer tout on va dire
les tenants et les aboutissants de ce
traitement
quels risques que j'encours et quels
effets secondaires je pouvais avoir
étant donné que mais mes symptômes de
base était pas très important à mon avis
et à partir de ce mois ces risques et
des effets secondaires qui vous ont été
expliqués et avez vous eu des effets
secondaires
eh bien écoutez on m'a dit que les
effets secondaires ça pouvait être la
nausée voilà un petit peu de être être
fatigué aussi mais rien de plus
important que ce que j'avais déjà
donc du coup je me suis dit que ça
valait le coup en fait on nous a pas ce
qui ce que j'aimerais dire de manière
très importante c'est qu'on nous a pas
dit que ça allait nous soigner on nous a
juste dit que ça allait baisser notre
charge virale qu'on a mais qu'on
n'allait plus être contagieux ou du
moins qu'on avait une période de
contagion d'environ 20 jours sans le
traitement et six jours avec donc du
coup bah j'ai décidé de j'ai décidé de
le prendre tout simplement vous protéger
les gens qui sont autour de moi même si
aujourd'hui je suis confiné et que je
vois personne je trouvais important de
justement ne plus ne plus être
contagieuse quoi vous parlez de nausées
on parle également de symptômes liés à
des problèmes ophtalmique ou encore wii
à des problèmes cardiaques est ce que
vous avez eu des problèmes à ce niveau
là ce que vous avez été informé à ce
niveau là également
oui en fait moi j'ai eues on va dire au
tout début mais symptômes et c'est ce
qu'ils m'ont alertée j'avais des quintes
de toux sèche que j'avais jamais eu
auparavant
j'avais très mal à la tête et en fait je
ne supportais plus je supportais plus la
lumière c'est à dire qu'en plus avec le
confinement les toute la journée devant
des écrans mais là je moi je suis
journaliste freelance je travaille à la
maison dont je suis sur l'ordi toute la
journée ça me gêne pas l'habitude et là
je ne supportais plus la lumière en fait
c'était c'était assez assez difficile
donc oui effectivement
moi j'ai eu ces symptômes la quelle est
votre réaction quand on sait que les
états unis ou encore le maroc autorise
le traitement est pas la france panda
écoutez moi aujourd'hui tout ça je
trouve ça très très politique
le fait est que moi j'étais assez
j'étais assez démunis la timone c'est on
va dire au bout de ma rue
et ce parti du principe que le centre de
méditerranée infection il est là depuis
bien plus longtemps il n'a pas attendu
le coronavirus pour être là et pour
étudier les infections donc j'ai préféré
m'en remettre aux mains de personnes qui
étaient un peu expert en la matière si
je puis dire
donc voila apres ben c'est sûr que le
protocole est pas
j'imagine forcément le même que
d'habitude mais bon à situation
exceptionnelle mesure exceptionnelle
j'en ai bien est ce que vous comprenez
les réticences d'une partie de la
communauté scientifique par rapport à ce
traitement
oui oui je peux comprendre parce que
effectivement j'ai bien l'impression que
le professeur house pas quelqu'un qui
qui fait forcément les choses bien comme
il faut
donc voilà je peux comprendre que des
personnes qui sont encore de métier
trouve que c'est un peu un peu prématuré
10 en mai mais après comme je tiens
encore à le préciser nous enfin son
équipe et lui se sont pas présentés
comme étant lé prophète et comme étant
ceux qui vont guérir à la france entière
mais plutôt on nous a dit écoutez ça va
baisser votre charge virale est
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est de 2,2
comment dire de réduire cette pandémie
quoi donc si on peut avoir un impact sur
votre votre dangerosité en feutre votre
contagion
on va le faire sur le site internet de
l'irfu méditerranée infections
d'aujourd'hui les chiffres annoncent
1291 patient jusqu'à la traiter à
l'hydraulique leur kiné à
l'azithromycine pour seulement un mort
jusque là motif d'espoir selon vous ah
bah oui oui motif d'espoir c'est un mot
aujourd'hui je me sens je me sens
beaucoup mieux et et je sors encore
enfin ce matin j'étais encore dans mon
âme au rendez vous de suivi est en fait
je vois bien que les jambes ça va ils en
sont à j-6 même parfois certains ont de
la chance et on sent déjà j-10 de
traitement et ça va beaucoup mieux ça va
beaucoup mieux alors que dans la file
d'attenté de dépistage en revanche il ya
plusieurs jours en arrière
il y avait des gens qui étaient vraiment
mal en point quoi donc ouais moi je me
dis que c'est un espoir est que ça l'air
de ça a l'air d'aller mieux en tout cas
pour les personnes qui sont traités
c'est le mot de la fin merci alors
accusé d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous avez été testée
positive au corona virus est soigné à la
chloroquine notamment à marseille